[Music]
the past holds within it a trove of
stories that continue to shape the
present and future
one such story is out of Andrew Jackson
the seventh president of the United
States who fatally wounded a man during
a duel in the early 1800s and instead of
getting condemned and thrown in jail for
it he received praise and recognition
that helped him attain the highest
political position in the country
in a time where personal honor was a
prized virtue Mr Jackson took the risk
of taking another man's life for the
sake of his reputation
Jackson's opponent was a man named
Charles Dickinson a hot-headed and
quarrelsome lawyer residing in the state
of Tennessee he was known for being a
skilled Marksman and a duelist and was
involved in at least 26 duels during his
lifetime the animosity between Jackson
and Dickinson had been building for
years fueled by insults accusations and
even a horse race that ended in
controversy one of the first disputes
happened in 1803 when Jackson served as
a judge in a case involving a debt owed
by Dickinson to a man named George Eliot
Dickinson had borrowed money from Elliot
and had not paid it back and Elliot sued
him to recover it as the judge in the
matter Jackson ruled in favor of Elliot
Dickinson was enraged by this decision
however and challenged Jackson to a duel
in response Jackson accepted the
challenge but the two men were prevented
from fighting at the time due to the
intervention of local authorities the
incident only served to increase the
tension between the two men and set the
stage for later confrontations
in 1805 at a horse race in Nashville
Tennessee Jackson entered his prize
Thoroughbred into the race and bet a
significant amount of money on him to
win
Dickinson who is known for his skills of
Horsemen and gambler also entered a
horse to compete during the race their
horses were neck and neck with Jackson
shouting encouragement to his horse as
they approached the Finish Line in the
end Jackson's Thoroughbred won by a slim
margin According to some witnesses
Dickinson was enraged by this outcome
and accused Jackson of cheating claiming
that by wearing weighted stirrups
Jackson's horse had an unfair Advantage
the argument between the two men became
heated and at one point Dickinson
insulted Jackson's wife Rachel
later that same year Dickinson published
a letter in a local newspaper accusing
Jackson of cheating and of having a
violent temper
he also again made insulting remarks
about Jackson's wife Rachel
finally the line had been crossed with
Jackson and he officially challenged his
rival to a duel to defend his honor and
thus on May 30th 1806 the two men met on
the banks of the Red River in Logan
County Kentucky the exact number of
people who attended the duels not known
but it's estimated that between 30 and
100 people may have been present to
witness the event that day according to
Witnesses the weather was hot and humid
with the sun beating down on the two men
as they stood facing each other the
atmosphere surrounding the duel was
tense and charged with emotion
both men were known for their fiery
personalities and quick tempers and the
insults and accusations that all led to
the challenge had only served to
intensify the animosity between them
despite the gravity of the situation the
rules of the duel were followed with
strict adherence to protocol and these
rules were simple 24 feet apart each man
with the pistol and the first to hit his
opponent would be declared the winner
after each man's assistance called
seconds carefully measured out the
distance between the two combatants the
two men stood silently glaring at each
other in the Kentucky sunlight and the
duel began Jackson took aim but
hesitated before firing Dickinson
however did not hesitate and fired his
shot hitting Jackson in the chest and
fracture in his arm Jackson Managed to
cover the wound with his hand to contain
the bleeding and while remaining calm
and upright he aimed and fired striking
Dickinson in the chest and fatally
wounding him
while Dickinson's assistance contended
the Jackson's first shot had misfired
which would have signaled the end of The
Duel Jackson had disregarded this
tradition by resetting his gun and
firing again ultimately causing
Dickinson's fatality though Jackson
would eventually recover from his own
wound the injury left him with
persistent discomfort throughout the
remainder of his life
not long afterward Jackson was charged
with murder by the authorities in
Kentucky but he was eventually acquitted
the incident caused a great deal of
controversy and was heavily criticized
by some who viewed dueling as barbaric
and archaic despite the criticism
Jackson's reputation as a man of honor
and integrity only grew following the
event
he would go on to serve in numerous
political positions afterward even as
the seventh president of the United
States and so the famous duel between
Andrew Jackson and Charles Dickinson was
cemented in history a tragic event that
highlights the importance placed on
personal honor and reputation in the
past while dueling may seem barbaric and
unnecessary today it was a commonly
accepted practice in the 19th century
Jackson's methods in the duel helped to
solidify his reputation as a man of
great integrity and courage a reputation
that would follow him throughout his
life and career
The Duel can also be seen as a pivotal
moment in American history a dramatic
clash between two formidable men that
spoke to the tensions and rivalries of
the era while the outcome of the duel is
a matter of record with Jackson emerging
Victorious but badly wounded the deeper
significance of the event lies and what
it revealed about the character of the
men involved and the broader societal
forces that shaped their lives for
Jackson The Duel was a test of his honor
and reputation a chance to defend his
wife's honor and establish him as a man
of courage and conviction for Dickinson
it was an opportunity to prove his own
medal and assert his dominance over
arrival yet in the end both men were
changed by the experience and the legacy
of their conflict would resonate for
generations to come
thank you
[Music]